hertz has placed an order for a hundred
thousand teslas the car rental firm
announced monday the cars will be
delivered over the next 14 months with
tesla model 3 sedan set to be available
for rental in the u.s and europe hertz
also said it will invest in
charging infrastructure to support the
fleet the order is a big boon for tesla
although it has drastically accelerated
output in recent years the company still
sells a tiny amount of vehicles compared
with giants like toyota and gm in 2020
automakers shipped 500 000 vehicles
worldwide as recently as 2017 tesla
delivered around 100 000 vehicles in
total tom brady will start in an
upcoming commercial touting the new cars
hertz said so
what are your thoughts i'm going to
start off with you here since this is
the story you wanted to talk about what
are your thoughts on this all right
let's roll you remember back in when the
when the when the bankruptcy when they
first filed for the bankruptcy they they
came out this big story they were giving
their compensation package 16 million to
the top 340 executives or something
right and everyone was like what the
hell is going on right
and we read that it said they were
giving it so they would stay on in terms
of the terms of the transition period
and stuff like this i took a dive into
this yesterday and i gotta say i'm
impressed this is a 104 year old company
they
the stock price was at 15 pre pandemic
the pandemic hits their it sinks to two
as a the at the low it was two dollars
right they sold 200 000 cars in the
latter half of 2020. what also happened
to used cars at this time prices
skyrocketed
up to 20 and beyond so here they're
selling a large part of their fleet
liquidating and and getting cash
restructuring the debt
and then they uh they went they were
delisted and then they came back and i
think yesterday i saw their stock was at
27
from two dollars to 27 yes so 13 and a
half facts yes you got to give him
credit for that so smart exactly you're
talking about pivoting talk about take
talk about leaning down the organization
and really restructuring and stuff like
that you think how much of this you
think they knew the chip shortage was
going to increase the car value how much
of this was luck
i think i think there's definitely luck
but a big part of it also is who who
anticipated the pandemic so that's also
bad luck the other way so i think it's
just more
no i don't i don't i don't i'm not
disputing that all i'm asking for is all
i'm asking about is the fact that
there's nobody a year and a half ago
that thought the chip shortage used cars
to go up 25
that's insane that never happened so
look this is the great thing about
business sometimes you get lucky and i
think this is a combination of a good
decision and some luck together no for
sure so now why are they doing a hundred
thousand tesla though well but think
about they're building the charging
infrastructure too and the government is
subsidizing ev infrastructure are they
not yeah so they're just being
subsidized and this is also in europe
and in the us well and elon musk
elon musk is incredibly rich now because
of this right he's worth what 288
billion
he's he's
well past jeff bezos yesterday
as of yesterday
elon musk by far and away the richest
man in the world it was neck and neck
with bezos do you have an opinion about
this yeah i think look i think you did a
nice little case example on hertz
specifically but i think overall this is
a just a microcosm of basically what's
going on in the world right now
everything is changing and the car
market is not immune to it right
whether that's people quitting their
jobs everyone's out of the workplace
right now the great reshuffle right the
great resignation everything that's
happened with that i mean kai i'm
shocked you didn't cover what norway is
going on right now every chance you get
you want to bring up norway norway's
going all green by how long right it's a
couple years from now okay everything's
going green everything's changing
um but there's one constant there's one
constant in the world for the last 20
years
and that's tom brady he's still out here
doing tesla commercials apparently or
commercials for hurts yeah well it hurts
tesla i mean this is what it is so
everything is changing other than tom
brady's greatness that's the message i
got here so be prepared you stand
consistent so gas obviously
um they got three zombies in the first
half the other day yeah and he's 43.
that's well four four touchdowns in the
first half
making this seem so easy cam newton's
like sums up with this guy with the
whole uh benjamin button deal i tweeted
out i said benjamin button aka tom brady
threw for four touchdowns the guy's a in
a league of his own well he had a bone
to pick with the bears
is this the whole aaron rodgers who
called him i own you i own you and he
comes i know that's that's that was that
was last week
he says
he says um
uh apparently aaron rodgers owns a few
shares in the chicago bears i don't know
if you heard him saying that
did you hear him saying that no that's
what brady said that's what brady said i
saw that aaron rodgers owning the bears
which he does yeah so what's the bone
typically no that last i mean very
rarely does tom brady make bone-headed
plays but last year
he threw some
you know long pass on fourth down he
goes oh [ __ ] i thought it was third down
like you're freaking tom brady what are
you doing so before the game or you know
you know
pre-game they were like tom
you know you lost to the bears last year
you guys end up winning the super bowl
you're good
you know bonehead play of the year on
your half he's like don't worry i got
something for you
this week he came out and just crushed
him how do you not love the guys by the
way the bat the
manning brothers what they're doing and
he said he says uh he says you know i
love playing against uh uh your brother
peyton and then eli says you know i
actually love playing against you
exactly beat you every time in the super
bowl peyton said hey tom don't you have
a curfew don't you need to go to sleep
tom's like it's actually past my curfew
i gotta go to bed that banter going back
and forth man these manning brothers not
only do they have talent but they're all
so funny they're funny and peyton's
funny
eli's got his style of fun funny thing
yeah yeah but but the lead is peyton
yeah yeah for sure peyton's definitely
the face of that person i missed the
peyton manning commercials those were
great for was progressive right
he's still doing stuff he's don't count
him out tyler he's not he's hustling so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you